G
WHICH FOLLOWED THE VERDICT.
>> Tucker: EL, REGINALD
DENNING.
WHAT DID HE DO WRONG?
HE WAS HAULING A LOAD OF
CINDER BLOCKS AND THEY BEAT HIM,
BRAIN DAMAGE.
THAT'S COOL.
BENNIE THOMPSON, CHAIRMAN OF THE
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE, DECIDED
HE COULDN'T CONDEMN RIOTING.
INSTEAD HE WAS WORRIED ABOUT
INJUSTICES AGAINST BLACK
OFFICIALS IN LOS ANGELES AT THE
TIME.
THE INJUSTICE WAS HAPPENING ON
THE STREETS OF L.A. AS THE CITY
WAS TORCHED AND RACE RIOTS BUT
HE COULDN'T DENOUNCE IT.
A CHAIRMAN OF CPAC JOINS US
TONIGHT, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
IT'S A LITTLE MUCH FOR THIS VERY
THING, PRECISELY THE SAME PEOPLE
THAT HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH REAL
POLITICAL VIOLENCE,
GRANDSTANDING AND
HYPERVENTILATING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH.
WHY DOES NO ONE POINT THIS OUT?
>> WHY DOES IT HAVE TO BE SHOWN
ON YOUR SHOW?
THE PUBLIC RECORDS OF THESE
ELECTED OFFICIALS IS THERE FOR
THE ENTIRE MEDIA TO SEE.
THE HYPOCRISY OF ALL THE TIME
THEY HAVE TAKEN TO THE FLOOR AND
TAKE INTO MEDIA TO SAY THAT
PEOPLE LIKE DONALD TRUMP OR NOT
LEGITIMATELY ELECTED PRESIDENTS.
ALL THE TIMES THEY HAVE NOT
CONDEMNED VIOLENCE OR IN THIS
CASE, YOU HAVE THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THIS OTHER
MEMBER FROM MARYLAND BASICALLY
SAYING, RIOTS ARE FINE IF YOU
HAVE A SOCIAL GRIEVANCE.
WHY IS IT OKAY FOR JAMIE RASKIN
TO GO TO THE FLOOR IN 2016 AND
SAY THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS NOT
LEGITIMATEY ELECTED IN THE
BENNIE THOMPSON CAN SEE THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS A LEGITIMATE AND
BOYCOTT HIS INAUGURATION.
BUT WHEN A RETIRED TEACHER OR A
MOM OR A DAD OR SOMEONE WANTS TO
GO TO THEIR CAPITAL IN PROTEST
WHAT THEY SAW AS AN ELECTION
RIFE WITH LOTS OF QUESTIONS AND
FRAUDULENT VOTING, SOMEHOW THERE
IS SOMETHING UNTOWARD WITH THEIR
DESIRE TO SPEAK UP.
WHY CAN'T THEY ALSO SPEAK UP AND
WHY DID BENNIE THOMPSON SAY THAT
JOSH HAWLEY AND TED CRUZ SHOULD
BE ON THE NO-FLY LIST FOR
RAISING LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION.
AT THIS TWO TIERED JUSTICE
SYSTEM, THIS TWO TIERED IDEA
THAT IF YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE
OR YOU ARE REPUBLICAN OR YOU ARE
A TRUMP SUPPORTER, YOU GET
THROUGH THIS KIND OF GHETTO
JUSTICE AND IF YOU OR SOMEBODY
ELSE WHO HAS THESE PROGRESSIVE
VIEWS IT IS FINE, IT'S JUST A
GRIEVANCE --
>> Tucker: BUT MOST AMERICANS
DON'T HAVE THE TIME TO FOLLOW
THIS.
THEY SENSED THAT SOMETHING IS
AMISS AND THAT IS WHY THEY VOTE
FOR A MEMBER OF THE SENATE TO
REPRESENT THEIR VIEWS AND SAVE
IT FROM THE OVERREACH OF
LUNATICS LIKE BENNIE THOMPSON
AND LIZ CHENEY.
SO WHERE IS MITCH McCONNELL
AND LINDSEY GRAHAM?
SHOOT MORE TRUMP VOTERS!
LIKE, DOING NORMAL PEOPLE
DESERVE REPRESENTATION?
>> THAT IS PART OF ALL OF THIS,
IF YOU WANT TO ASK REAL
QUESTIONS, WHY DON'T WE ASK
THEM?
WHY DON'T WE FIND OUT THE REASON
WHY THE CAPITOL POLICE FORCE, WE
JUST FOUND OUT THIS WEEK,
BECAUSE OF JUDICIAL WATCH, AT
50% STRENGTH.
HOW WAS THAT ALLOWED TO HAPPEN?
WE ALL KNEW IT WAS GOING TO BE A
TUMULTUOUS DAY.
THESE ARE THE QUESTIONS THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO ANSWER.
YOU KNOW WHY, TUCKER?
BECAUSE WHEN POLITICAL VIOLENCE
BENEFITS OF THEM, THEY TURNED A
BLIND EYE TOWARD IT.